as we mentioned earlier at this hour
president Trump in the first lady are
hosting their first official state visit
with French president Emmanuel macron
and his wife we expect to see them do a
photo op for the press shortly just
outside Mount Vernon the home of George
Washington but beyond all the pomp and
circumstance there are some very big
issues for the two leaders to discuss
correspondent Kevin cork starts us off
tonight on this visit from the White
House could even Kevin hey there my
friend you're right in historic night
coming up for the president as they host
their first state dinner now actually
that is tomorrow night here at the White
House but as you mentioned they'll be
dining this evening over at Mount Vernon
spending time together but ahead of all
the pomp and circumstance Bret comes a
great deal of concern about some US
positions on some pretty delicate
international policies all this
happening in a week that will certainly
be marked by diplomacy and some major
decisions it's a return engagement for
the French leader
president emanuel McCraw coming to the
US just nine months after he rolled out
the red carpet for President Trump on
the Shawn's Alizee this state visit is
very important for our people and very
important for us however this time the
two men will discuss a host of pressing
issues that threatened to divide the
longtime allies from the Iran nuclear
deal to the conflict in Syria - what to
do about North Korea's nuclear ambitions
transatlantic trade and tariffs NAFTA
even the environment all part of a
high-stakes week of diplomacy that will
also see German Chancellor Angela Merkel
follow McCrone visit to the White House
we have an incredibly good negotiator at
the table for the United States but what
you do have are two leaders who have a
great deal of respect for one another
who have a great friendship certainly
both have a great deal of interest in
doing what is best for their country
mccombs music continues a tradition that
spans generations but one that is
increasingly strained by a politically
truculent president whose america-first
agenda is now forcing allies to
reevaluate their approach to
transatlantic policy like the USS role
for example in the six-party Iran
nuclear deal
what is the what-if scenario or your
plan B I don't have any plan B for
nuclear are against against earrin but
Crone's comment drew a tweet from the
Iranian Foreign Minister who said he was
correct in saying there's no plan B it's
either all or nothing
not surprisingly the White House bristle
we certainly think that there should be
a better deal one that actually is
positive that works and we don't really
typically look to the leadership and
Iran to determine what our foreign
policy is while some policy experts
believe that McCrone and later Merkel
could come up with enough concessions to
keep the President on board they also
warned that time for European leaders is
running out the president has been very
clear that if the Europeans don't agree
to fix some of the flaws in the deal
that on May 12th he will tear it up so
we still have a month or so to go I'm
hopeful that the United States and our
European allies can come to an agreement
to close some of the holes in the deal
holls like finding an agreement on
ballistic missiles and inspections and
even some of those sunset clauses and
there is renewed hope tonight here at
the White House Brett that perhaps the
White House could be close to achieving
some of those concessions but they're
not announcing anything just yet back to
you
Kevin cork live in the North Lawn Kevin
thank you